tucker carlson is now starting to
prepare his audience
for what he believes is an indictment of
donald trump that is coming now there's
a couple different reasons why tucker
carlson may be doing this one of the
reasons may be that he is trying to
soften the blow and preemptively sort of
deflate what may be coming so that when
it happens he can say we knew this was
going to happen this is this is part of
the scam it's part of the witch hunt
whatever tucker carlson seems to be
pretty friendly with trump right now you
might remember that a few weeks ago at
this
uh excuse me saudi-backed
live golf tournament liv golf tournament
at bedminster in i think it's jersey
uh tucker carlson and marjorie taylor
green and trump were photographed
together hanging out so tucker clearly
has some kind of vested interest in this
and he is now kind of just saying as an
aside the indictment's coming it's not
even if it's more a matter of when
there's something to see here
that's the line and no doubt asa
hutchinson and mitch mcconnell and dan
crenshaw and the rest of them will be
telling you the very same thing when the
biden justice department
or some other state law enforcement
agency under their influence finally
does what you know they're going to do
which is indict donald trump obviously
they're going to do that so the point
here is saying
these people are so biased these people
are so in the tank against trump they
are so viciously determined to damage
him that the indictment is coming but
it's going to be a bogus indictment it's
not going to be based on anything
who knows how maybe they'll produce
surveillance video from mar-a-lago
apparently they've already subpoenaed
that we'll spend the next year talking
about how it shows trump mishandling
classified information
really
on the server remember the endless
russia collusion hoax we're in for a lot
more of that the endless russia
collusion hoax which led to
37 indictments
and so many people
ultimately pleading guilty that it
recovered more money than it cost to run
that investigation that's the witch hunt
tucker is talking about that's
revisionist history they'll scream at
how trump is a criminal and if you
express any support for him or any
interest in retaining i don't know the
rights of free speech and due process
you're a criminal too now of course
trump's rights of free speech have not
been restricted in any way by those
investigating him it is true that he was
banned by twitter two years ago has
nothing to do with the investigation has
nothing to do with the first amendment
private company with terms of service
but
that
this trump has been saying whatever he
wants and he can get interviewed
wherever he wants at least in right-wing
media anytime he wants and in terms of
due process all the eyes have been
crossed and t's dotted i know as sean
hannity said last week in fact you are
the threat you're the threat and just
mentioning that you disagree with what
is happening is an attack on our
government that's their style just the
other day after signing off for the
mar-a-lago raid your attorney general
merrick garland came on stage to whine
about how actually he was the victim
here he's the victim apparently some
people disagree with the raid so the fbi
the most heavily armed domestic law
enforcement agency in the world is now
under threat
from you
well yes that is absolutely true there
were death threats to fbi agents
gunmen showed up at fbi offices
including in cincinnati tucker is
completely unhinged and he wants us to
believe that the victim here is trump
trump's had his his free speech taken
away no he hasn't trump's had due
process denied no he hasn't and it's
really trump that is the victim so there
is the view from tucker tucker who
recently hung out with trump at his golf
club he is in a position to give us a
really honest and unbiased assessment uh
now the other thing that i think is
interesting is
the right seems to be talking much more
about an indictment than the left many
on the left are sort of resigned to a
possible fate which is this isn't going
to go anywhere in terms of indictments
the right continues to say oh they're
going after this guy i was looking at
the conservative subreddit the other day
and they're going on and on about how
there's a secret grand jury in dc that's
imminently going to indict trump
why are they starting rumors about their
own guy going down is it a sort of
negative visualization in the the the
style of the stoic philosophers i don't
think so is it about
diffusing the power of the indictment
when it eventually comes because then it
looks more like a plot rather than
actual justice and due process maybe
or is it all to rile up the extremists
so that some of them commit the
stochastic terrorism that many of us
fear is coming
solely because the possibility of
violence
may actually interfere with the
investigation
and when there is actual violence
it's probably useful to many of the
people that are supporting donald trump
globally to put it lightly i don't know
the answer but you're hearing a lot more
indictment talk from the right than from
the left so there's tucker's view if you
think tucker is able to fairly assess
the situation that's his perspective
that an indictment is coming but it is a
bogus indictment
one of our sponsors today is feels feels
is a premium cbd designed to help you
feel your best delivered right to your
door with everything going on in our
daily lives we all need to take a moment
to relax and that's where feels comes in
many people report cbd helping with
anxiety stress and sleeplessness if you
have aches or pains there are people who
use cbd as a safe natural method for
relieving pain without side effects
feels cbd oil is awesome the cbd infused
mints are great they leave you with
fresh breath you can try feels caffeine
free focus melts to get you through the
afternoon slump feels even offers a free
hotline with experts to give you advice
about cbd dosage finding the right
starting point and when you join the
feels monthly membership you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time become a member
today get 50 off your first order with
free shipping when you go to fields.com
davidp and use the code davidp the link
is down below